hezekiah of judah who had not submitted
to my yoke i've received 46 of his
strong cities castles and small cities
by casting down their walls and
advancing the war engines by an assault
of the light armed soldiers by breaches
by battering and by axes i took them two
hundred thousand one hundred and fifty
people young and old male and female i
brought out from them with horses mules
asses camels oxen and sheep without
number I counted them as spoil Hezekiah
himself I shut up like a caged bird in
Jerusalem His Royal City I fortified the
walls against him and whosoever came out
of the gates I turned back after I had
plundered his cities I divided them from
his land and gave them to meet in t king
of Ashdod to party king of Ekron and to
steal Baal king of gaza and thus i
diminished his territory to the former
years tribute I added the tribute of
subject Alliance to my lordship and lay
that upon him as Akaya himself was
overwhelmed with the fear of the
brightness of my lordship the Arabians
and his other faithful warriors whom as
a defense for Jerusalem his royal City
he had introduced fell into fear thirty
talents of gold and eight hundred
talents of silver precious stones large
lapis lazuli couches of ivory Thrones of
ivory ivory valuable wood of every kind
a heavy treasure
and his daughters his harem women the
young men and young women of his
household I caused to be brought after
me to Nineveh the city of my lordship
and he sent me ambassadors to give
tribute and pay homage
[Applause]
in dealing with the conquered king of
elam and his men their necks I cut off
like lambs their precious lives I cut
through like a knot the charges of my
chariot swam in the masses of blood as
in a river blood and filth run down its
wheel with the corpses of their warriors
as with herbes i filled the field i'm
mutilated my captives horribly i cut off
their hands their bracelets of gold and
silver which were on their arms i
plucked off with sharp swords
i cut off their noses
[Music]
you
[Music]